dropshipping seit jahren ein unendlich
riesiges thema auf youtube mit
unzähligen uploads in allen erdenklichen
sprachen jeden tag vermutlich hat jeder
von euch schon mal sachen gehört wien
fünf tagen acht gesetzten 162.000
was ist wirklich dran an diesem ganzen
thema was ist dropshipping wie
funktioniert das ganze und ist es
wirklich für jeden möglich innerhalb von
kurzer zeit viel geld damit zu verdienen
ihr könnt es euch schon denken genau
diese frage habe ich mir auch gestellt
viel spaß mit wie schwer ist es in 72
stunden mit dropshipping reich zu werden
aber was ist trumpf chefin überhaupt im
prinzip eigentlich ganz einfach irgend
jemand verkauft eine leistung von jemand
anderem das bedeutet wenn wir mit
dropshipping website haben verkaufen wir
das produkt von jemanden der
beispielsweise in china oder irgendwo
anders auf der welt im prinzip sind die
webseiten einfach nur eine vermittlung
zwischen kunden und verkäufer und
anschlägen die betrag mit brauchtum mit
an diesem verkauf zu verbieten wir in
unserem dropshipping job also erst
iphone hüllen anbieten und die an
jemanden aus deutschland verkaufen
würden wir die order einfach an die
person in china weiter geben die würde
das versenden zu der person schicken und
wir bekommen aber das geld dafür und
verdienen und so eine im besten fall
goldene nase meistens laufen diese
webseiten oder systeme über shopping
frei was ein fertiges shop system ist
besser leben für alle wenn ihr egal was
online verkaufen wollt baut euch einen
job das beste was ich machen konnte
genau damit fangen wir jetzt auch am
basteln uns irgendwie einen job zusammen
der uns vom stil her passen dann suchen
wir das produkt was wir verkaufen wo er
mit 14 44 ich plane dass wir heute abend
noch mit dem shop online gehen können
und vielleicht heute sogar die erste
sache verkaufen können das ding ist wir
haben nur 72 stunden zeit desto früher
wir also anfangen zu verkaufen desto
mehr zeit haben wir geld zu verdienen
also das ist echt starten und den jobs
abbauen
ich habe noch keinen millimeter an
meinem job gebaut aber ich glaube ich
habe gerade die über trance power idee
gehabt die perfekt in die jetzige zeit
passt die leute sind zu hause die leute
haben viel zeit es wird bald weihnachten
und leute lieben personalisierten kram
was passt also besser als
personalisierte adventskalender wenn ich
also ein drucker der im besten fall in
deutschland sitzt findet der
personalisierte einfach standard
adventskalender mit schokolade druck
während das
der option um jetzt produkte zu
verkaufen das wäre der reiz zeitraum
danach werde ich jetzt suchen und damit
werden dass stichtag 1 habe ich mir
komplett geblockt nur um die website zu
bauen obwohl shop ein fertiges system
ist zieht sich der gesamte prozess viel
länger als gedacht dinge wie das layout
der website für mobilgeräte vernünftige
produktfotos allgemeine vernünftige
inhalte für die website und auch agb
impressum und dieser ganze scheiß nehmen
unendlich viel zeit in anspruch viel
mehr als ich jemals gedacht hätte
außerdem stoße ich immer wieder auf
probleme die scheinbar nur mit html
programmierung lösen kann wovon ich kein
bisschen ahnung habe und wofür die zeit
auch nicht reichen würde zumindest hab
ich ein großhändler gefunden welcher
personalisierte adventskalender
vertreibt und nicht mit ein wenig druck
am telefon und ein bisschen glück noch
am selben tag einen geschäftskunden
konto eröffnen lässt ich beende tag eins
also mit einer halbfertigen website und
dem gefühl dass das hier sehr sehr eng
werden könnte tatsächlich hat jetzt
alles deutlich länger gedauert das sind
jetzt über 24 stunden her also 28
stunden sind wir konnten die komplett
fertig zusammen natürlich habe ich auch
schon eine domain gekauft christmas
kalender punkt de so sieht die website
aus das ist quasi die landingpage auf
jetzt gestalten gehen dann können die
leute hier beispiele sehen wieder
adventskalender aussehen könnte sie
können hier ihre eigene datei hochladen
und den rahmen auswählen jetzt geht es
darum dass wir neue kunden finden ich
habe genauso wenig ahnung davon hier ich
muss jetzt irgendwie herausfinden wie
ich facebook kampagnen gestalten kann
durch die hohen laden kann und wie ich
im besten fall welche mache wo die leute
erreichen die dann auch wirklich ein
kalender kaufen
der kalender kostet 20 euro im einkauf
ich hab den jetzt für 29 95 drin das
würde bedeuten das wären 9 euro und 95
cent gewinn pro verkauft möglicherweise
ging es ja sogar heute abend noch hinter
der kampagne an den start zu bringen und
vielleicht sogar schon irgendwas zu
verkaufen das wäre zumindest sein als
ich will jetzt keine zeit mehr verlieren
deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade sonne
ganz standard basic kampagne
zusammengeschustert die einfach nur das
produkt auf facebook zwischen normalen
beiträgen an zeigt dadurch kennt seine
das werbevideo oder so viel gemacht da
wird einfach nur das produkt angezeigt
mit einer schrift gestalten sie ihren
ganz persönlichen adventskalender
feinste lindt schokolade hinter jedem
türchen sparen sie 10 prozent mit dem
pro weihnachten und dann schauen wir mal
ob das schon was bringen während diese
standard kampagne jetzt an der stelle
ich mich darum kümmern ein video für die
nächste kampagne zu produzieren
ich glaube es ist gut dass wir mehrere
kampagnen parallel laufen lassen um dann
sehen zu können welche davon
funktionieren und welche nicht
funktioniert das hier ist ein guter
start aber das ist noch nicht das
maximum nicht
30 euro und damit starte ich let's go
ich arbeite dann quasi noch den
kompletten abend von tag 2 an allen
möglichen kleinigkeiten der website und
probiert zu verstehen wie man wirklich
funktionierende werbung erschaffen kann
außerdem merke ich ziemlich schnell dass
ich ein neues problem habe von dem ich
vorher nicht wusste dass es existiert
werbekampagnen auf facebook müssen
mindestens 24 stunden laufen mit der uns
noch verbleibenden zeit haben wir also
quasi nur zwei möglichkeiten zu checken
ob die werbung die wir erschaffen haben
wirklich funktioniert und überhaupt
leute auf unserer website bringt oder
nicht tag 2 zeigt sich also dem ende zu
und ich fühle mich genau wie nach tag
eins ich habe das gefühl dass das
niemals was werden kann und wir haben
nach wie vor 0 produkte verkauft meine
anfängliche enthusiasmus schwindet so
langsam auch und ich habe das gefühl
dass ich mich einfach komplett
überschätzt habe und frage mich ob ich
mich wirklich so sehr von dieser werbung
habe beeinflussen lassen dass ich mir
eingeredet habe dass einfach die sie
machen zu können
es scheint so als wäre es doch alles
nicht so einfach wie gedacht hat nummer
drei ich habe meinen anfänglichen
ehrgeiz wieder und noch nicht rein
geschaut ob dir irgendwas verkauft haben
und wenn die werbekampagne funktioniert
hat aber lasst uns das direkt so wir
haben null produkte verkauft perfekt und
30 euro ausgegeben über unsere 30 euro
werbekampagne konnten wir 21 link klicks
generieren ich glaube das ist nicht
besonders gut als nächstes werde ich
jetzt die daten dieser kampagne
auswerten und schauen in welcher
altersgruppe das wie gut funktioniert
hat und dann für die einzelnen
altersgruppen nochmal einzelne kampagnen
schalten in der hoffnung dass wir dann
endlich leute finden die lust haben
unser produkt zu kaufen mittlerweile
habe ich aber wirklich das gefühl dass
nichts mehr wird weil wir uns für das
falsche produkt entschieden haben bei
irgendwas an meiner website nicht stimmt
ich kann es nicht so richtig verstehen
aber es ist auf jeden fall schwieriger
als gedacht und es bleiben nur noch 24
stunden raum gebaut damit wir das jetzt
zum laufen bekommen also es ist auf
jeden fall schwieriger als ich am anfang
gedacht hätte ob es jetzt mal schaffen
ich habe keine ahnung und motivation mit
ex spieler und auch an tag 3 geht das
ganz normale arbeiten wieder los ich
schaue mir an was bei der letzten
kampagne gut funktioniert hat und was
vielleicht nicht so gut funktioniert hat
bei den sachen die gut funktioniert
haben da packen ein bisschen mehr geld
drauf und probiere die zielgruppe noch
ein bisschen genauer runter zu drücken
so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe ist
das eine der standard möglichkeiten um
in facebook marketing seine zielgruppe
immer weiter genauer zu definieren und
die werbung neben gezielter zu schalten
nach unzähligen stunden youtube und
einer menge videos die mir probiert
haben zu erklären wie ich vernünftige
facebook werbung schaltet stehe ich am
ende von tag 3 wird von verschiedenen
werbungen na ja gut
viel mehr kann ich daran jetzt nicht
machen ich muss jetzt schauen ob die
kampagnen funktionieren das sehe ich
aber erst macht 24 stunden das ein
bisschen doof aber das ist eben eines
der probleme das man hat wenn man
schnell ein shop in shop errichten als
absoluter profi ist es dann vielleicht
möglichst sofort super gezielte werbung
zu machen die funktioniert ohne
erfahrung sind die 72 stunden schon
wirklich sehr tight gesetzt aber wir
werden sehen jetzt heißt es warten und
hoffen dass wir morgen zumindest einzel
über unsere website generieren können
okay freunde tag nummer drei finaler tag
jetzt kommt es zur auswertung und wir
schauen ob wir ein produkt verkauft
haben oder nicht bevor ich das aber
mache möchte ich ganz kurz darauf
eingehen wie die letzten 72 stunden für
mich noch grundsätzlich muss ich
wirklich sagen es hat mir nicht
besonders viel spaß gemacht diese
website zu bauen und nicht mit diesen
gesamten thema zu beschäftigen in den
videos wo ich leuten zugeschaut habe die
darüber gesprochen haben hat das immer
ein bisschen spaßiger gewirkt als ist
jetzt am ende vergeblich für mich war
das bedeutet insgesamt ist es jetzt
nichts wo ich mir vorstellen könnte dass
ich das längerfristig machen möchte weil
es einfach keinen spaß gemacht hat die
große frage ist jetzt haben wir ein
produkt verkauft oder nicht werde sofort
nachschauen ich kann mich aber schon
sagen profitabel sind in keinem fall wir
haben nämlich jetzt ungefähr 110 euro
für werbung ausgegeben mit knapp 10 euro
gewinn pro verkauf müssten wir also
mindestens elf artikel verkauft haben
damit wir wenigstens break even sind
treff artikel also damit wir ein
bisschen gewinn gemacht hätten ich kann
es mir beim besten willen nicht
vorstellen auch wenn es schön wäre jetzt
kommt es zur auswertung wir haben einen
artikel verkauft hat einen kalender mit
seinem bild und einem weißen rahmen
gestellt das bedeutet wir sind 100 euro
im minus mit diesem projekt das hat also
rein gar nicht funktioniert wenn neue
job vorher davon ausgegangen dass es
überhaupt kein problem sein sollte also
ich hatte immer das gefühl das ist super
easy sei und ich hatte auch das gefühl
dass mir die videos das in irgendeiner
weise so suggerieren aber dem ist nicht
so wenn ihr mich also dabei unterstützen
wollte sich mit diesem video ein
bisschen weniger minus gemacht habt
lasst sie kennen leichter und abonniert
mich damit er kein video mehr verpasst
wir sehen uns nächste woche macht gut